didn't fully rotate all the way out to
quarters kind of encouraging him to
shoot that's part of the scholarly tool
James from the baseline really haven't
played a lot of minutes together and
they only playing about thirteen and a
half minutes a game step back
yeah it's back
you might only want to free
first quarter the Rockets need a lot
from him tonight Jackson to the Miss
third pace their two ones yeah
now here's third base he was shortstop
he was second he was in the outfield the
guy could do everything keeps getting
into the paint Gasol is the helper
coming over to try to stop it and he
does not stop it and wishes that he
probably didn't try to stop it was
totally about the team whatever is
necessary shade would do it and that's
why I always love the Duque
between the double-team they had a boxed
in Gasol just goes a little bit too far
to James's left and lets him split the
double-team at the end and gets him on
the arm right there and James with the
grenade spin on the bolt rockets have
slowed this down to play the Memphis
style of basketball they can't run they
don't have anybody on the other end they
got harden though for five from behind
the arc
harden working on Cass B goes flying
right by
in the first half he's had 31 there's a
steal by Harden and he's going to have
34
and nobody told Gasol Gasol was saying
hey let's get a little communication